We're going to go deeper into understanding the shapes of distributions.
Interactivate has its own data sets that you can play around with, so let's
check out Body Fat percentage of 252 Men. Here, you can see that it looks like
it has on peak, pretty much right in the middle. And if we change the shape of
the distribution, you can see it always peaks about here. At maybe 21% body fat.
Again, sometimes when the bin size is too small, you can see it's really, really
small Then, there's a little too much detail. And when the interval size is too
big, there's not enough detail. This is probably a pretty good bin size around
this area. Let's stop at about here with the bin size 2.662. Now, let's take a
quiz.